welcome to this blitz game on to this
video yeah this is a five-minute gave me
again on the icc against tactic was
check your master made veggie yeah i'm
going to play it bogo style yeah but
this is the stuff that I know or selfie
this is why I play it let's see in this
okay check this is an interesting line
my black gets a nice development in
return for his bishop pan I mean the
bishop had that he gave up let's see how
wide plays Bishop to g2 is normal here
on also pin Queen deform or this has
been played number of times yeah quindi
force is the usual move but it's not
doing that Oh interesting i wonder if i
can use this in some way
when I can break in play that 94 94
Bishop d7 night be three sm is good for
me so I can play 96 e 5 now he will just
capture but night if I it was actually a
move that I thought would be interesting
let's try that the idea is that while
Queen takes Knight b3 is definitely good
for me and well light takes Bishop g2
KNG to e5 the night moves then night xb3
so okay yes some we had some things up
his sleeve but anyway 94 Bishop g2 is
not dangerous anyway even if i don't
have a five-night xp3 let's see what he
does yeah he just covers this okay so
means that I have some flexibility now
with my move I can even consider just d
6 m trying to to cover this you might
take with the bishop though okay he
might take with the bishop but I can
also do this right this is a very simple
approach but why not
I will just take on c4 whatever he does
yeah here I can take with with basically
any peace even with even with the bishop
I could take for night be three year
this is this kind of thing Queen Queen
takes is also possible I mean it's no
reason not to take with the Queen but it
was an interesting interesting question
it all looked quite attractive actually
now okay night be three rupee one this
does not make that much sense probably
and so just jump here yeah maybe bishop
deform is a simple continuation that you
can play and I probably a some
yeah you can do that it's not bad or
anything this move okay look the eight
maybe the other one just centralizing I
don't I didn't see anything particularly
great the idea of this move is to move
the Queen and then use this pin on the D
file so I'm not quite sure what he what
he should play now I mean you can just
take f6 and so on play it very very
simple manner but this definitely won't
travel me at all okay
I've got the more active pieces so looks
fine in general let's see what now
Queenie for looks fairly logical trying
to try to trade and the teggy too so I'm
not sure what his move is now maybe look
see one or something IFIF be five though
and unfortunately I cannot take anywhere
okay let's let's play it simple and just
keep the night down hoping to use them
active night but it's probably not
really anything for me yeah this is very
typical of the the Catalan and those
kind of openings mm-hm not much else
than taking what now okay eight maybe
that's probably not mattering very much
it's a very equal ish position anyway
I'm going to take probably i'm going to
take now
i yes night to d3 all the time and can
try to claim an advantage but I doubt
that it really has one yeah 95 is the
way to do it tonight see 596 s very
equal er would be ADA it's not what you
want to do that's bit that's a bit
uncomfortable
yeah that's not too great this decide
this is a really miss played I had no
problem whatsoever and now I have one
check and so on I'm out of problems
again check of course I can still I know
do something stupid normally I shouldn't
lose this
check
sure
that's completely equal material of
course but it still looks it looks
slightly tricky due to his activity
sewed a little bit more active but I'd
say that is the draw come on now with
check the bloody cheeky I didn't think
about that but just feel it wrong ha ha
ok game tada yeah no use rook against
rook he's slightly behind on the clock
this would be a few day for mr. Ollie
goes yeah I got myself into some trouble
there from a really good position around
here I'm just fine but I really I didn't
do that too well what did I do wrong
greene takes before so still night be
three yeah I had my doubts about this
simply because the night is the night is
somewhat it is right in the in the heart
of the position would be one and I don't
know nitey one I was always afraid of
night you want maybe this is completely
completely wrong I don't understand it
actually this is what the what the
computer wants to do whatever what am i
doing against this a nightie for no one
this is I didn't think about the self
pin yeah the comp says I'm almost
winning but it's very difficult to walk
into this kind of self pin mmm yeah I
didn't trust this night be three more
this is why I went here with this
probably sports mymy whole my whole
advantage young and this is now just
just about equal
yeah this is really just nothing if
anything wide is this a little bit more
comfortable it yeah this is a plate a
little bit too relaxed yeah this was not
necessary yeah here for example I can do
all kinds of moves they are meant for
example rook da droop d5 than 95 or
something this was not really precise
now I'm passive and this is something
and this Moses was really badly played
but I think what he did wasn't so
testing yeah I guess he might be able to
UM to play this a bit slower laura is
king cannot enter I still have very
serious drawing chances but I'm not
quite sure how he should play it
chime very difficult now maybe white
cannot win it's possible that is not
nothing you cannot do something
seriously it's always always it's better
better for him and all the time but here
I think we are there already in draw
territory yeah I should definitely not
lose and I can probably play better than
I did I just try to play quickly but it
really should should keep things within
the drawing range huh yeah a shame but
93 is a very hard move to play for human
eye I simply I simply did not think
about um yeah here and okay look look to
differ and I did not ever consider to go
into the self pin this is a very
computer ish way to play in a way yeah
and the queen is depending on this and
Bishop takes Queen takes this chick made
here and so on it's all based on some
some tactics and yeah this is some very
difficult for a human at least for a
human of my level to find okay well
thanks for watching